[Music]
hey guys it's silas from
harry potter theory uh i know i'm not on
camera very often
but today is a very special day and it's
special because the channel has reached
000 quarter of a million subscribers
which is absolutely mind-blowing for
those that aren't aware there are
actually two of us that run this channel
myself
and star wars theory and though you may
hear my voice in the videos
he's a massive help behind the scenes
and none of this would have been
possible without him
i actually remember vividly hitting a
milestone of 30
000 subscribers last january so 250
000 just one year later is absolutely
insane and
i can't thank you guys enough anyway the
point of this video was really just to
say a big thank you to
everyone new and old who's helped get
the channel
to where it is today because without you
guys it wouldn't have been possible
i know i'm not on camera very often and
to be honest i'm not particularly
comfortable
on camera but moving forward i am going
to make a conscious effort to be a bit
more present
with all that said i just want to say
one more big final thank you to everyone
that's helped
i couldn't have done any of this without
you and i promise to keep making regular
harry potter content
[Music]
you